gonna begin with something you're all
familiar with health care costs are
rising a recent Gallup survey found
Americans borrowed an estimated eighty
eight billion dollars for medical
expenses one major problem no one really
knows what anything costs this morning
CBS News kicks off a new series it's
called medical price roulette we're
going to explore the reasons behind
confusing medical bills and this is a
collaboration with clear health costs a
journalism company focused on
transparency our consumer investigative
correspondent and a Werner is here and
I'm so glad we're doing this no kidding
eighty eight billion dollars people
borrow it to cover medical costs what'd
you learn yeah where and if you ask
anybody about medical bills you'll
probably hear their nightmare story a
bill that came as a surprise or a bill
they didn't understand the problem is
costs vary and pricing isn't transparent
and one Long Island New York man found
out just how much that could cost him
I'm an average working person I'm not
I'm not a millionaire I go to work every
day like everybody else
Frank Esposito is a tool and die maker
for the last year has been fighting for
his financial life
a fight he says began last March with
unrelenting back pain it's kind of back
pain that just wouldn't go away no
matter what you did
Esposito is an active person but says
back then he could barely move an MRI
soon showed a bulge in his spine a
herniated disc and when he went to see a
specialist he said you need to go to the
closest hospital immediately immediately
immediately he says doctors at the
emergency room told him he needed
surgery herniation was so severe that it
could have severed my nerve in half so
you would wind up paralyzed paralyzed
for the rest of my life the next day
they performed a fusion which Esposito
says successfully relieved his pain but
the next month the bills started coming
your statement says please pay two
hundred and twenty thousand eight
hundred and fifty dollars and that was
just one bill in total his bills added
up to over six hundred fifty thousand
dollars money his insurance company said
he would have to pay they claimed his
back surgery was not an emergency and
not medically necessary
what was my choice just be paralyzed for
the rest of my life then to get these
bills that was so overwhelming you say
that this can't be real though I mean I
really don't have to pay this how am I
gonna pay this and you sit there and you
start crying because you don't know what
you're gonna do he's not the only one
for in 10 consumers polled in 2018 said
they received a surprise medical bill in
the past year half of those were over
$500 another study found over a
five-year period consumers out-of-pocket
medical costs went up more than 50
percent even if they had health
insurance from their job nothing about
the United States health care system
really makes sense Aaron Carroll is a
pediatrician and health services
researcher who says there's no
transparency in health care pricing this
is somebody who's in pain and now it's
been told okay you might be paralyzed
unless you run to the hospital how are
they supposed to become good shoppers
and make complex rational decisions
they're going to say please tell me what
to do because that's your job even if
it's not an emergency we found there can
be surprising swings in what a given
procedure or test can cost our partner
clear health costs surveyed cash prices
price is used here as a benchmark for
comparison in two major metro areas
Dallas and San Francisco for a simple
blood test prices ranged from ten
dollars to a hundred seventy six dollars
in the Dallas area in the San Francisco
Bay Area from 15 dollars up to 126
dollars the cost for an ultrasound of
the abdomen in Dallas ranged from $115
to an estimate of two thousand four
hundred fifty nine dollars from a
hundred dollars in the Bay Area to 28
hundred dollars and where the prices set
can affect your cost whether insured or
not I think people have a an assumption
for right or wrong that insurance is
going to protect them if we pay that
much we think we're going to be covered
and we're not going to see that surprise
bill so when you do people are shocked
if I'm hearing you correctly you're
basically saying that people should not
expect their insurance to protect them
isn't that why we have it so there's
protecting this protect plans will have
different deductr
most aromatic coinsurance that our
amount of co-payments and it also
depends of course what they're charging
what the price is and then how much you
are responsible for that price Frank
Esposito finally chose to hire and pay
extra for a company to negotiate those
bills for him but he still owes over
$220,000 and doesn't know how he'll pay
you work all your life you work to buy a
house you work to have a house you have
to save up everything we would like to
be able to know that we can go to doctor
that we can get healthy that we can get
taken care of without losing everything
we have after Appeals
Esposito's insurer Oxford United Health
Care did pay some of his doctor's bills
we're still waiting for a response as to
the remaining two hundred twenty
thousand dollar bill he's already taken
forty-nine thousand dollars out of his
401k shield for mr. Esposito and he's a
perfect example of how screwed up the
health system is the prices you gave it
seemed to be so arbitrary fifteen
dollars to one hundred and twenty-six
dollars we also get this movie I've
gotten this one your insurance comes
back from from a procedure and they bill
you for you know twenty five hundred
dollars insurance then says I'll we'll
pay you 800 and you look at this and go
well what's the actual price does
anybody really know and what was I when
ago she ated this and nobody that's the
answer is nobody really does know and
while you're on it they put so many damn
numbers on the bill you can't even read
the bill so everyone's putting this
roulette wheel when they get a bill that
they can't pay how do they negotiate it
down how do they fight it you know you
should try to fight it it can be
difficult sometimes the doctors have to
appeal we have posted tip tips and
resources on our web page and we also
want to hear from you we want to know
what you're paying for medical
procedures around the country so go to
CBS news.com slash health cost see the
button there share insert your prices
share what you paid you can also search
the prices that we surveyed in the two
markets and you can see what those
numbers were that we found I hope people
do this please please do physically okay
he's walking yeah he's good now the
fusion worked for weighing on his mind
clear right you do wonder what
obligation they should they have to
people like him to say when they're
going into surgery
by the way this is basically gonna wreck
your life yeah here's what's gonna cost
here's what's gonna cost more tomorrow
more prices more it'sit's a talker yeah
everybody's got the story on this one